liz cheney stands up for the truth
she may lose her position in the party
she may even lose her career as a
politician
but that is something to be admired
standing up for the truth
if it doesn't fit you must acquit
i think the final nail in liz's
political coffin
she just won a not so coveted
endorsement
she got the endorsement of i kid you not
o.j simpson
now there's a clip o.j simpson has
actually a very funny twitter feed where
he
posts videos of himself i'm not going to
play it
and the reason that i'm not going to
play o.j simpson's commentary on my show
is that o.j simpson is a double murderer
who got away with his crime and i just
can't bring myself
to give this guy air time and and listen
to him and look at him on tv
however it is a
telling circumstance that o.j simpson is
endorsing liz cheney here the rule of
law
liz cheney standing up for the rule of
law and and defended by um
oh the most infamous murderer alive in
our country right now yes the rule of
law
he endorsed cheney he said
it seems that the big truth and honesty
seems to be the enemy of many of these
republican politicians
and liz cheney stands up for the truth
that's got her a lot of heat
she may lose her position in the party
she may even lose her career as a
politician
but that is something to be admired
standing up for the truth that's
something i know her father wouldn't
have done so he doesn't
oj doesn't like dick cheney but right
now i'm kind of a fan of liz cheney
this this liberal talking point that
you're hearing repeated not just by
double murderers such as o.j simpson but
you're hearing it from all the left-wing
talking heads
and you're hearing it from liz cheney
herself is so
grating i can't i hate it i hate it
stop collaborate and listen collaborate
with me by ringing that bell
like and subscribe otherwise you're just
not going to get notifications for these
videos
frankly even if you do you might not get
notifications because our overlords here
at youtube are not uh
not always so happy with me but the best
way to have a chance of knowing when our
new content comes out is to
ring that bell do it today see you next
[Music]
[Music]
time